Neville's parents in their tragic story
never Longbottom's parents Frank and
Alice Longbottom were auras who were
tortured into Insanity by Bellatrix
Lestrange and other Death Eaters
Neville's relationship with his parents
is a key part of his character
development as he struggles with the
trauma of their condition and the
pressure of living up to their legacy
the reason for Neville's parents being
omitted from the Harry Potter films is
still not clear however there are a few
possible reasons the verse being that
their storyline may have just been too
dark the second possible reason is that
filmmakers may have instead wanted to
shift their focus to Neville's character
development highlighting his growing
confidence and bravery rather than his
dark history